Je pense qu'il est le film le plus étrange et le plus interrogatif de toute ma vie !
il me fascine mais j'ai aussi l'impression d'être pris pour un con
..Et quoi qu'il en soit, c'est très improbable de tomber sur un film où la fin est propre à chacun..
..Et donc différent en fonction de votre pensée.
Toutes les fins peuvent être bonne en fonction de ce que vous avez compris
c'est un sentiment réellement étrange mais on le doit Alex Garland
BREF ! Une sorte de météorite tombe sur la terre et plus précisément dans un phare situé sur la côte.
Mais cette météorite amène ce qu'on appelle le "Shimmer" soit en français le : Miroitement
Une Zone particulièrement étrange qui s'étend de jour en jour
Cette zone modifie : la nature, la vie, les cellules, l'ADN
Je reste encore tout bizarre en repensant à ce film et je n'arrive pas à me sortir de la tête..
C'est pourquoi j'aimerais vous proposer un 3 THEORIES le concernant.
Rentrons donc dans le miroitement et attaquons les théories !
Je dirais que vous confondez suicide avec autodestruction
Très peu d'entre nous commettent un suicide...
..Et la majorité d'entre nous auto détruit. D'une certaine manière à un certain moment dans la vie..
on boit, on fume, on met en péril un boulot en or...
Ou un couple des plus heureux.
Cette scène est vraiment révélatrice du film et est plein de philosophie.
Lena est celle qui a poussé Kane à faire cette mission.
le couple que nous croyons heureux a été en fait
détruit par l'infidélité de l'ena envers kane. Ce dernier ayant connaissance des actes de son épouse a décidé..
de faire cette mission du "Shimmer" en n'ayant donc plus rien à perdre
Nous pouvons d'ailleurs le remarquer à la froideur de Kane au moment du départ
Lena comprend donc cette démarche et entame une sorte de rédemption envers Kane
En terminant la mission qu'il a commencé.
si nous nous tournons encore plus dans le côté mental du film
Lena était forcément la seule survivante de la mission non pas car elle est le personnage principal...
mais parce qu'elle n'est plus dans cette optique d'autodestruction !
..Ou suicide comme elle l'entend !
Josie avait déjà tenté de se mutiler et donc de se suicider
Anya avait déjà accepté sa mort avant même que la mission commence
Et pareil pour Ventress qui était prise d'un cancer bien avancé
bien sûr, Sheppard était dans cette même optique
de : "Je n'ai plus rien à perdre je sais que je ne reviendrai pas"
Tout ceci est d'ailleurs compréhensible dans la scène où Lena et Sheppard échangent entre elles sur la barque
On comprend que seule Lena est ici pour se "racheter" techniquement
Auprès de Kane. Et qu'elle possède donc encore l'espoir de revenir et de le sauver.
Pourquoi irait-elle s'autodétruire dans cette mission alors qu'il est revenu d'entre les morts au bout d'un an d'absence ?
Simplement.. Elle lui "devait bien ça" mais ce n'est pas exactement la théorie dont j'aimerais vous parler
Dans cette idée que j'ai imaginé le Kane présent en train de se faire soigner serait en fait le véritable Kane
Et non pas le clône comme il est sous-entendu.
Pourquoi ça ? Tout d'abord à la fin nous voyons Kane avouer ne plus savoir où il en est..
..qu'il ne sait plus ce qui est réel ou non et surtout il demande à son soi-disant clone de retrouver Lena
Kane d'après moi était dans la même optique que Lena. Il était fou amoureux d'elle et malgré ses erreurs..
Il entama un "processus d'autodestruction" en effectuant cette mission comme certains pourraient se mettre à boire, fumer ou pire encore.
mais il le regretta et dans les moments de doute, de souffrance, son coeur se tourne toujours vers Lena !
Kane n'est donc pas fait pour mourir.
il a même d'ailleurs atteint le phare et rencontrer l'entité surnaturel qui se matérialisa en être humanoïde le copiant..
physiquement et..
mentalement
Cependant nous ne savons pas combien de temps Kane est resté avec son double.
Souhaitant apprendre ce qu'est d'être un humain, son double aurait pu
ne pas supporter la souffrance de Kane et se tua face caméra, n'arrivant pas à devenir un véritable humain.
Ce qui d'ailleurs appuie cette idée est que nous pouvons
comparer le "Kane revenu" à Lena !
Lena n'est clairement plus la même retour de son expédition
Elle est changé mentalement.
J'ai même d'ailleurs cru qu'elle était le "double" au départ
laissant la véritable Lena, morte dans le phare
C'est la même chose pour Kane. Il est allé effectuer cette mission le cœur lourd et trahi. Puis revient un an plus tard totalement changé.
Certainement dû à son expédition et au "Shimmer".
Quand Lena demande à Kane à la fin :
"Tu n'es pas Kane"
"N'est-ce pas ?"
"J'crois pas.. non"
Kane aurait changé en revenant de son expédition
Il n'hésite pas à enlacer Lena comme s'il l'aimait depuis le premier jour et qu'il était heureux de la retrouver
Puis ce qui me dérange aussi est que Kane tombe gravement malade après être sorti du "Shimmer" et est soudainement guéri quand l'entité est détruite.
Si il est le clone de Kane, pourquoi n'a t-il pas brûlé comme l'entité copiant Lena ?
Et comment se fait-il qu'il connaisse l'endroit où habitaient Kane et Lena ?
Ce n'est mentionné à aucun moment du film.
Si nous comparons l'interrogatoire de Lena avec celui de Kane, les deux semblent aussi perturbés l'un que l'autre à leur retour
Enfin, la chose que je ne comprends pas est que nous sommes en présence d'une seule entité à la fin du film
Qui a déjà pris l'apparence de Kane normalement !
Puis quand Lena arrive, elle est de nouveau présente et prend la forme de cette dernière.
Alors que le clone de Kane existe toujours !!
Peut être car le "suicide du clone" aurait pu permettre un "Reset" de son existence ?
Ou peut-être à cause de Ventress qui permis de re-créer une entité ?
Après... Malgré que le film permet d'imaginer beaucoup de choses, des contre-arguments sont présents.
Déjà par rapport aux vêtements de Kane..
..Et sa coupe de cheveux. Ce ne sont pas les mêmes que celui qui était de base allé dans la zone
C'est d'ailleurs perturbant comparé à Lena qui possède une copie conforme d'elle-même.
De plus Kane mentionne le fait que :
"T'as déjà vu explosé une Grenade au phosphore ?"
"Il y a une grande lumière !"
"Protège tes yeux !"
Son double est incapable de savoir ceci !
Puis le double de Kane en sortant du "Shimmer" tombe gravement malade.
Certainement car il n'arrive pas à s'habituer à l'environnement de la terre ?
Mais il aurait dû normalement partir..
Quand le "Shimmer" fut éteint.
D'ailleurs dans les livres, Kane se serait apparemment muté en Dauphin
Ce qui confirmerait que nous sommes bien en présence du double dans la zone de quarantaine.
Je ne sais vraiment plus quoi penser...
Peut-être qu'au final il est le vrai double de Kane et que c'est au final le double de Lena qui a survécu dans le phare et s'en est allé ?
Non ! Ce n'est pas logique !
Je ne sais plus ce qui est vrai ou faux.. *Soupir*
Hm...
Vous avez déjà vu une grenade au phosphore exploser ?
Il est clair que la fin du film nous confirme que le miroitement est toujours présent en Lena et le double de Kane
Ce qui est normal pour lui après tout !
Donc nous pouvons clâmer Haut et Fort que toute cette histoire reviendra et n'est pas encore finie.
Je ne suis pas sûr qu'un annihilation 2 verra le jour
Mais, quelles conséquences engendre cette fin ?
Tout d'abord nous savons que Lena est obsédée par l'immortalité !
Elle affirme toujours que nos cellules sont la cause de notre finalité et que si elles se réparaient constamment, nous pourrions vivre éternellement.
elle en parle très souvent et lit même des magazines à ce sujet.
Le miroitement permet de modifier génétiquement toute espèce vivante vivant dans le "Shimmer"
Nous le remarquons tout le long du film avec par exemple : Le crocodile avec la dentition d'un requin, Les fleurs...
...Ou encore ce f*cking Ours qui me donne froid dans le dos !!
"AIdeZ-mOi"
Qui possède la voix de Sheppard certainement car il l'a tué au niveau du cou et donc des cordes vocales !
ENFIN BREF J'ai pas envie du tout envie de parler de lui. Le miroitement permet donc d'évoluer et de modifier nos cellules.
Chose que l'Humain a très peur : L'évolution
Contrairement à Lena !
Kane étant le double du véritable Kane (normalement)
..Est la source du "Shimmer" et possède donc le miroitement en lui, C'est logique !
Lena.. C'est pareil de son côté !
Suite à la fin du film où elle est allée à la source du phare elle est infectée par le miroitement aussi.
Et depuis qu'elle est infectée, un tatouage est apparu au niveau de son bras..
Symbolisant : L' "Ouroboros".
Un serpent qui se mord la queue.
Sa position forme l'infini, soit : l'immortalité.
Et le fait qu'il se mange la queue
symbolise : l'autodestruction
2 Thématiques importantes du film.
Ce détail qu'elle ne possédait pas auparavant peut largement signifier que Lena est maintenant : immortelle
Car ses cellules se régénèrent éternellement à cause du miroitement présent en elle
Ce tatouage était à l'origine sur le bras d'Anya
Mais suite au "Shimmer" et aux péripéties du film, il est apparu sur le bras de Lena
un détail et un message caché affirmant son éternité et donc son éternelle jeunesse
Puisque ses cellules se re-fabriquent constamment maintenant.
La présence du miroitement en Kane et Lena nous affirme que l'entité a "gagné"
Puisqu'elle est toujours présente et que le miroitement refera son apparition.
On nous affirme tout le long du film qu'on  ne sait pas ce que voulait cette chose.. Ou si il voulait quelque chose !
On ne sait absolument rien de lui..
On ne peut donc rien affirmer sur lui.
Toutes les théories le concernant sont alors possibles dont celle d'une sorte d' "invasion extraterrestre"
puisque le "Shimmer" reviendra forcément avec Lena & Kane.
Le but de cet être est donc peut-être de..
Modifier la nature et la vie de la terre !
Et qu'il a appris de son échec face à Lena, ne réussissant pas à devenir Humain.
s'étant fait avoir par Lena, justement.
Contrairement à Kane, qui lui a appris à devenir un humain et à devenir lui-même en prenant son identité !
Un mystère à jamais non-résolu puisque rien n'a été confirmé sur le film
même les acteurs possèdent leur propre conception de la fin.
j'aime cette idée de partir de rien et concevoir sa propre vision.
Ceci est une cellule !
Pour finir j'aimerais vous proposer une autre vision du film.
Le film commence avec l'arrivée de la météorite du "Shimmer" sur la terre
Puis enchaîne avec un cours de Lena.
Une ancienne militaire devenue professeur de biologie où elle parle d'une tumeur d'une femme
Le film traite par moments de cancers ou de tumeurs.
La Terre avance normalement dans le temps et "vit" au jour le jour !
Mais cette météorite tombe sur terre et provoque une sorte de dysfonctionnement de cette dernière
Modifiant et perturbant toute la vie qui l'entoure..
Et chose encore plus surprenante, cette zone créée par le "Shimmer" s'étant constamment de jour en jour.
Jusqu'à un moment où la terre sera engloutie par cette zone !
Et cette maladie de la terre s'adapte à son environnement en essayant de copier ceux qui l'habitent.
Je pense que vous avez compris où je voulais en venir !
Le miroitement est en fait la métaphore d'un cancer.
La météorite arrivant sur la terre symbolise l'arrivée du cancer dans le corps humain.
Ce dernier provoque un dysfonctionnement, exactement comme dans le corps humain.
Il modifie et perturbe les cellules de notre corps
Et justement ! Ces cellules sont en fait symbolisées par la vie présente sur terre.
Notre corps est composé de milliers, de milliards de cellules regroupés pour former les tissus et les organes.
les gènes présents dans le noyau de chaque cellule lui indiquent quand se développer...
...travailler, se diviser et mourir !
En temps normal nos cellules suivent ses directives et nous restons en santé.
Mais lorsque notre ADN est modifié ou endommagé...
...Un gène peut subir une mutation.
Les gènes mutés ne fonctionnent pas correctement, parce que les directives dans leur ADN sont confuses.
Ainsi, les cellules qui devraient se reposer, pourraient se diviser et croître de façon désordonnées.
Ce qui peut mener... au Cancer !!
ADN modifié.. ou endommagé..
Cela ne vous rappelle pas quelque chose ?
Chaque être vivant sur terre est là pour une bonne raison.
On peut prendre l'exemple d'un Lion qui tue une Gazelle
Il permet de se nourrir mais en même temps éviter que trop de Gazelles peuplent la Terre !
Ils sont comparables aux cellules permettant de faire fonctionner un être vivant.
C'est la loi de la nature et marche pour chaque être vivant
Cependant vu que leur ADN est modifié et même endommagé par le Miroitement
La Terre se porte mal dans la partie où elle présente le "Shimmer"
Comme le crocodile-requin, les fleurs..
Ou ce fameux enf*iré d'Ours
Toute la Faune et la Flore est perturbée et provoque donc un dysfonctionnement qui s'étend de plus en plus chaque jour..
Exactement comme un cancer qui se développe dans le corps humain, grâce à la perturbation des cellules présentes
Alors... Oui !
On ne sait pas ce que voulait cette entité extraterrestre !
Ou si elle voulait quelque chose ?
Mais c'est tout simplement comme un cancer !
Est-ce que le cancer possède un but ?
Est-ce qu'il veut quelque chose ?
Non !!
Il est une maladie juste se développant et qui provoque un dysfonctionnement.
Exactement comme le miroitement au final.
Ce dernier essaye d'ailleurs apprendre de son environnement...
...En copiant les cellules de la terre, soit les humains et la vie qui entoure notre planète
Annihilation n'est pas un film comme les autres et il m'a marqué.
Je le range dans cette catégorie de films comme "Interstellar" ou "Premier Contact"
...Traitant de science fiction en essayant de rester dans le réel et qui donc nous amène à une grosse réflexion !
Ce sont en général mes films préférés !
j'espère que ma vidéo vous aura plu !
Merci à ceux qui laisseront un pouce bleu et qui partageront cette vidéo
Suivez-Moi sur Twitter, c'est important !
Dîtes-moi ce que vous avez pensé de ce film en commentaire et quelles sont vos théories.
Je serais curieux de lire votre vision par rapport au sujet.
Que le LionHeart soit avec vous !
....Ah Oui !
Vous avez déjà vu l'explosion d'une grenade au phos.....